có trang trong cái vị, làm gồ sơ, sách tuyên các bạn không biết chỉ sẽ cùng ai.
Thì các bạn có thể là bởi vì các phem bài của nhà trường.
Thì chúng tôi cũng sẽ luôn đồng hành và giám chấp các bạn đến các áp lực.
Để các bạn không phải quá thành đảm bà.
Khi thế sao để các bạn có tích quá, như thế nào, thì tôi nghĩa các bạn là
cũng không đơn quá.
Tự máu vì tích rất bỏ mình tóm bởi vì đây là phía trên hoặc tiếp theo.
Khi thế sao cũng tính tảy mới hỏng thành một cái cạnh đường thôi.
Hỏng một cạnh đường tiếp theo rất là cạnh cạnh có các bạn là tiếp là phía cái những lực.
Để không phải không tà lợi chọt những cái mình không.
Hình ở đây là các bạn có mẹn cơn những cái chiến thọt này, cái bây giờ.